cool so these are these are classical
things maybe in our little subfield
right this idea of recovering and
detecting and that there's this uh
detection recovery gap for some problems
and this is a sort of new problem we've
called Counting right so it's another
testing problem
cool and so one way to sell this story
is uh with the phase transition diagrams
another way to sell the story is uh I
think that there's some really nice
combinatorics going on under the hood
both for um
sort of testing problems and and
Recovery problems which uh
questions
okay so let's let's get started so uh
the planted dense Matrix so the model
will be uh thinking about it when it is
planted dense sub-matrix right and so
we're going to have additive gaussian
noise and the idea is we just have
um
some vertices uh which will be in our
community which I've denoted with this
sort of Blue Dot and each is going to be
independently in the community with some
K on N probability so we're expecting
the community to be sort of
approximately size K right at about n
and these ones we give them a slightly
reasoning okay
so the algorithmic questions you uh
could ask right uh sort of to determine
um so if you're given either uh
a sample from this model or a sample
from the model where you don't have a
race mean you could determine which one
uh you could try and uh recover some
things or perhaps try and get an
estimator over a particular vertex
whether or not it's inside the community
and uh accounting which we'll uh talk
about in a sec so the um
these are sort of the existing phase
diagrams and I haven't really started a
few properties right so this is a lot of
work I went into these uh two two
diagrams and um
yeah so the idea here is you have uh
some sort of null right so everything
here is normal zero one you've got to
raise mean on a little bit of it
and you've got uh recovery and the
really nice thing right is that these
are not quite the same
so there's these regions where detection
is easy and the recovery problem is
impossible and also where it's uh
there's evidence of hardness and there's
two different types of hardness there's
some reduction type stuff and there's
also a low degree hardness oh so
basically we want something where the
sum test would fail
um so we want to instead of having one
planted Community we want to have M
planted communities such that the the
total uh sum is the same as in the one
planted Community case right
um and so if you think about how you
would do that right so you now we're
going to have uh the vertex label so we
still want the the total size is going
to be approximately K right so
um
and if you wanted equal sized
communities right that would mean that
you would Place each each vertex into
one of these sort of M color classes
with probability okay like one on M
times K on n again until you get this
and so you notice that the sum is
correct right so each of these things
will give you one on M times there's a
Lambda K squared okay so the sum is
going to be the same as if we just have
one planted community and the idea is
that we we are really going to be
interested so we're going to say
counting say is telling the difference
between
um
so in the most basic case just having
one uh planted some Matrix
or having a the situation where we have
and communities
and so we don't want the trivial thing
to work because I had the different sums
that would like differ by a constant
Factor the trivial thing would work and
would be easy in that whole green region
whether some test works right so this is
why we've set it up this way
and so
um yeah and we get uh the same
the same diagram basically so uh in the
case where say we distinguish
this
uh on Corinthian too it's the same uh as
the
the phase diagram for recovery
which is maybe surprising right like
it's a it was easier to detect
communities they're like to detect the
presence of one
one thing like show existence of uh
communities and now we're saying that
well actually it's not easier to just
count them you don't have to recover the
communities you just have to count
so
um what's a formal statement so to say
it formally so uh that most of the work
in this paper went into the low degree
bounce right so showing that on the
loaded group polynomial works and so by
low degree this is this idea right this
uh conjunction maybe in uh the thesis of
um Sam Sam Hopkins right that we
consider that if if we have a
low degree polynomial where low can be
up to log n size so it covers spectral
stuff if that if that works then we
consider we have a working algorithm
anything higher would be consider too
slow right so uh and by working we mean
that we want this uh difference in mean
to overcome
this uh fluctuations right so in this
situation
so we've got two two different uh
problems for example it could be uh the
situation where we just
uh sorry I've gone back to the graph
case here because these are the budget
site but yeah so you could have either
um sort of no plantar structure or you
could have this one or you could have
this K and one for example and
um
you want that when you have
um your graph or your Matrix structure
sampled from one of these then your
polynomial is going to be high in one
and low on the other with a bigger Gap
than the difference in the square root
of the variance right okay so this is
what we mean and so under this
this is where we prove hardness right so
um
we have so I'll state it in the simple
case of uh counting one versus m first
so here we have reasonably tied results
right so
what we say is that uh
there's an easy test so the easy test in
this case is we sum up the diagonal so
we made
the the sums of the whole thing
uh match but then the sum on the
diagonal the more communities you have
you're going to get like M Lambda times
this K versus having only
one okay so you have a degree one test
um
whenever
whenever uh sort of that counts is uh
highly concentrated or not correct and
otherwise we can show uh
so the actual formal problem is you're
given you know that you'll be given one
of two samples one of them will have end
communities
right and so it's a testing problem
s
so they need to make it a little bit
closer to Counting uh it actually all
goes through if you actually have em
communities with some different Networks
this all works if the that now then you
need some stuff about either the max of
the two numbers or the difference but if
those are the same order
here we're talking about the the sorry
uh the binary model right so here we
have um
uh some more parameters okay so I
so this should be an S right so now what
we're interested in is um
so here here you're going to reveal
edges with probability uh Q Plus
um
Ms and here is just going to be uh
everything is like an Oddish so you sort
of got this background erish random
graph with probability q and then
uh here you have some sort of higher
probability and you have to be careful I
guess this is not greater than one but
that's this is this is a model in the
binary case and then uh we also know
you know some things but here the story
is a little bit different so here we we
don't have any diagonal entries right so
we set I guess I should say here that we
set uh the diagonal uh we say there's no
self-loops right so this is whenever U
and B are separate vertices we reveal
the edge with these probabilities
and so when you do that then uh you get
the following right so if you take a
signed triangle test uh this is our this
is our um this statistic that we use
um
yeah
and you'll see so here the dependence on
M is not not strong anymore right so
it's still open with the correct
dependence on these these two M's are so
perhaps some sort of
yeah there's a that's that's still open
um and we also have this extra condition
here
um which says that the expected degree
in the planted structure is large right
so this is the expected degree of
expected planter degree of the vertex
and plantar structure we also want to do
that
um so
um
uh the nice thing is okay so
getting slightly about the friends on M
D but these are these are the right
professionals uh in terms of uh being
the same as recovery
here uh the recovery uh in uh Alexis
Lewis paper they also needed this
condition and some sort of conditions
great great yeah so I want to talk about
this uh reduction because I think it's
really nice so
um the idea is that
um basically our proof that it's it's
hard to test between these two problems
can uh give a new proof that recovery of
a single block is is hard right so
why is this interesting so normally
maybe I mean if if detection and
Recovery had the same thresholds then
you could use uh whenever it's hard just
between the
having one block of zero blocks right if
that was where if that was hard uh
um whenever recovery was hard then you
could maybe use that in your reduction
but for us that that has uh to have
different balance whereas uh this
testing problem does have the same sort
of structure as this right so then it
makes sense actually for this to have a
more complicated testing structure
testing problem
um so it's harder to test basically
um and then we can use it to prove
hardness of this algorithm so where we
want to prove it right is uh where
recovery is is hard so that's this line
here and so we're allowed to sort of
assume this
algorithm would be useful
okay so the idea is we're going to be
given one of these as input so either
the one or two so in this case we can
really restrict to this like one verse
two case right because we we know this
is hard in various regions and what we
want is a
office okay so we have one of these we
don't know which we can apply the
algorithm so
we're Imagining the algorithm recovers
in this situation right so we know that
if the input is uh sort of our H naught
then the algorithm Returns the right
thing okay so we get this
The Annoying Thing is we have no
guarantee about
what happens in in the situation where
this is the input right so then the
algorithm could return sort of anything
right it could return any K by K block
perhaps an empty one you sort of Imagine
maybe you would return the one with the
plantar structure you know so I've drawn
a few options here
but
we do have the guarantee here it's going
to return the red thing and here returns
something else okay and so
um now you've got this K by K block you
want to do some tests and so one thing
you can do is calculate just the sum of
the block okay so in the situation maybe
you're expecting so if there is just one
block then you get this sum
right and otherwise
um so we've normalized it right so the
sum of the whole planted structure is
the same
um so if you don't pick up all the
plantar structure you're going to get a
lower sum
right and this concentrates quite quite
well so anyway here you can sort of
imagine you're getting very close to
these values
um
yeah so you can if the sum is bigger
than sort of what it's meant to be minus
a little bit then you must be in the
situation that uh
so
in in each naught you're in this
situation for free in each one you now
know that you're pretty close to this uh
picking up the plantar structure right
you might have some sort of like Epsilon
cool and then once you've got once you
know that you're vaguely in the right
area then you can calculate the sum of
the diagonal of the K by K block and
that's going to distinguish it for you
right because um
the diagonal
in your original case is going to give
me Lambda K whereas a the diagonal if
you've picked up most of the plantar
structure and the two Community case is
going to be like almost too Lambda key
so you can threshold on the sum of the
diagonal
oh yeah this is just saying yeah you did
need to do both tests right because
sometimes you could if you the diagonal
will say this uh
which is a subset of the
two communities if you give me one
Community about two then you would have
the sort of
like the right some of the diagonal even
though uh
let's appear in this case
that's okay and so now I want to talk a
little bit about
um maybe some of the print techniques
because uh I think it's it's really nice
so
um
you end up defining these um these
things right and so these will
eventually be uh random variables which
are to do with uh the probability model
p and the probability model q but uh
everything we need about them basically
holds sort of a formal binomial so you
can imagine that you've got a bunch of
variables which are indexed by sets
another a bunch of variables which index
bisects and it sets and you can
recursively advantage and so you get
this sort of nice calculations right so
if if you're um
probability spaces are exchangeable then
all you care about is sort of the
structure of the graph you don't care
actually which
which edges are in the set just sort of
like how they relate to each other in in
a sort of a graph which is similar to
what's Leon and Alex had
first Leo and Alex they had things which
turned out to be actually cumulent so
ours are not sort of obviously cumulant
we'll see maybe sometimes they are but
um so this is the
um
the non-recursive definition and somehow
it it feels a little bit like cumulance
right so uh if you if you forget this
this first term so usually in in
cumulance right uh you'd have the sum
overall Tau which are partitions of your
set and minus one to this the number of
parts in Tau minus one and then you get
a Tau minus one factorial and then you
take a product over
uh
the the expectations over just sort of
like uh your random variables which are
in which are indexed by the parts each
of these properties we do actually use
in the proof right so we use things like
if you've got um
to
you're sort of thinking about these ages
France right so if the edge sets are
disjoint and uh our formal A's are
multiplicative over these uh and our B's
are then we get that these r's are
we'll put a dip over these things Okay
so
you
um
basically we get some more complicated R
structure than you might hope you would
sort of hope you would get cumulance in
some way in which case then uh instead
of instead of being a modification you
just get to zero whenever you have this
joint sets and we don't have that we
have the like next strongest thing which
is that it's multiplication so we sort
of don't have to worry about destroying
correct
if you have this and you don't
necessarily know that these things are
more delicative but if you assume they
are then you get the
um
you also get that if these things are if
you have a set set of these things such
that these a a and b values are zero
then you get out that uh for some sort
of like
um close set so it can set up for us for
example when you delete edges and stay a
forest so if that's true then you get
that these R is a zero that
um
like
yeah okay and so maybe we should say how
actually they relate to the set so this
is the formal definition right so here
I'm good
this we care about this situation
precisely right so it's say additive
gaussian noise which is the only way
when these our office makes sense okay
so we see this and these are alphas are
a function of the planet okay
and so for any for any subset we just uh
we can index the setting space right
there's a product of every every Edge in
that set
um yeah so often we only care about the
um the growth structure of these things
right
we do care so you don't just care about
the size of the set you sort of care how
the entries are related in general
because these are eventually going to be
the expectation over these things are in
the two different models being used
right so you sort of care about the
graph structures
um yeah so then the A's and the B's are
formally exactly this right so if you're
so I guess um we're thinking most of the
sub nitrogen undergrad sorry but you so
you're you're giving a graph
um or you sample your um your Matrix
like this and then it's a function of
the planted vendora
in both cases
and so
yeah this is the the two ways you'd sort
of Define it either recursively so you
have to unpack it or not aggressively
it's maybe a little bit closer but it
looks it looks like this
so this is
uh this is the story and we have to
bound the sum of the squares of these
are apples eventually
so one
well what property we use so this gets
back to your question about how we get
the crawler of the binary case and it's
not just thresholding but what we can
say is that uh yeah somehow uh what we
care about is the planter structure if
we can
who can uh apply signal sorry if we can
shift that by some constant
then these these R's don't actually
change
and that helps us work it out yeah and
so here I wanted to show another
property uh which is like not quite
cumulus but they're nearly cumulates
right so say you have some uh
there are sort of three different
problems going on and you can either
have so the this type of structure this
plant structure but you imagine that
independent okay this x-hat and X tilde
and then if you define the plantar
structure which is the sum of both of
them
then uh
the the advantage you get so these These
are are going to be larger sort of
thinking is helping us uh tell apart the
the two models and somehow it's a nice
convolution of these uh
for the individual problems okay so
these were cumulates again you just have
a sum of RG of one and RG of units
but what we have
to discuss a little bit how it relates
to the uh the thing that's going on with
um arts and sales paper right so
um advantage in
this uh
this chord these are the idea is that if
these are large you can tell things
apart and if that's more you can't right
and in both cases when you have additive
gaussian noise
these are
we have we have proofs that sort of
follow you turn the same handle right
and you get that uh so Alex and sleal
had this and we have this right
um
and then if you if you unpack the
definition of what everything is so
maybe I've told you a lot about sort of
AD infinite and what these our Alphas
are and they have some sort of nice-ish
properties they're not very nice
um it was really nice and Alexander's
case is you've got these cumulants right
except it's cumulance over maybe
something
sort of an interesting set right so
here if you're looking at uh this K
Alpha it's the cumulant over which round
of variables so the ones indexed by
everything in Alpha but also the thing
you're trying to estimate right so
in that case this was like the community
membership of say vertex one because
literally what the the paper was about
right so this is
um
okay so and then it's this uh cumulant
of uh
of these and so to remind people what
the definition
of the cumulant is
that's this right
yeah so maybe one one thing that's nice
in the special case Okay so let's say
um all right so when you're thinking
about a recovery problem
um
let's say you're trying to
be sort of the recovery distribution is
this right because we have to make it
one of our distributions
and then so formally if if we
if you have some
um
function X which is just a function of
the plantar structure and it has this
property right then these two things do
reduce to being the same okay
and so because here it's sort of maybe a
little bit hard to see sorry from all
that's going on but here we get mostly
the same terms right so we mostly the
two things are in terms of these
expectations of Q of sum X Alpha and so
in sales and Alex's paper right they
have this
sometimes you're uh you also look at the
set together with uh this this x right
yeah exactly so basically so if if this
this um
this likelihood ratio right if it really
exists
right then our thing although it's not a
cumulant over these variables it is when
you add this
as a random variable so in our
particular case so it has to be that the
the ratio of those two things has to
exist in the planter structure for the
for us it wasn't actually true this time
right but you can imagine sometimes it
was and then you're saying that it sort
of makes sense right you're saying that
the testing problem is estimating this
ratio so there's a problem is uh well I
was in slow analysis paper but I think
it's super nice so we have this uh uh
okay so just thinking about the low
degree versus uh where that's possible
or not right so here we have this
um but somehow
um
and
here we had this right but somehow this
was kind of cheating right because we
did a sum test so if you just make sure
there's some matches you get a little
bit closer
uh and so you get this diagram actually
that it becomes a
it's not easy right in all of this
region uh as when you sort of compare
against a null which has zero mean the
slightly raise mean it means it's a
little bit harder somewhere else and I
think and they also have a version where
they uh get second moments to be correct
and push that down a little bit
um but not all the way right so it'd be
really nice to have some H naught which
is not obviously Community structures
right so somehow we we fooled we fooled
things by uh we couldn't tell this apart
from some other bunch of communities but
if you design some different H naught
which doesn't look like a bunch of
communities and it was still just as
hard to tell apart from this one blunted
Community I think that would be really
nice